but I I I think history this is a very
charitable assessment I think history
will record Bill Clinton as the first
president of the 21st century as as as
sorta in that way and he would like this
very much but in that way as the Teddy
Roosevelt of his time in that I think he
saw the future and he didn't get us into
the future and he didn't achieve nearly
what he wanted to and it's disappointing
and historians tend to be very
disappointed in it in the present day
David Kennedy of Stanford described it
to me recently as the great squandering
you know is how historian see the
Clinton presidency but I see something a
little different which is he didn't get
us into that future but he did define it
he created a political lexicon people
didn't talk about the Information Age
the new economy the globalization the
global economy yeah we throw these words
around now like they've always been here
they weren't here and Bill Clinton said
on on factory floors and in airport
hangers and said to people you know this
is not your father's economy it's never
going to be again the world is changing
it's going to be painful for you but
it's also full of promise and we can't
stop it and he wasn't the first one who
made that I really Gary Hart predated
and there were other there have been you
know some visionary politicians but he
was the most persuasive and the most
successful and and what Clinton left us
as a legacy and it may be a paltry
legacy by some standards is that is a
lexicon and a debate and a language we
can use a sort of basic understanding in
order to have the conversations we
really need to have and I think I think
when the history is written what they'll
say is these conversations are never
linear in American life that you had
Teddy Roosevelt and you had Woodrow
Wilson he had Franklin Roosevelt but you
also had Taft and Hoover thrown in and
nobody remembers that and that was kind
of a step backward from the move toward
a an industrialized society and a
centralized government and and I think
similarly people will write you know in
a hundred years that you know Bill
Clinton was the first president to find
the challenge of the 21st century and
that the country then took a real step
back from that conversation that they
elected a president george w bush who
who you know in a sense believed you
could hold back some of that change and
and
and and probably he won't be the last
president we have who who who makes that
conversation less productive rather than
more but we'll get there